good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
monday which i think we used to frown
upon but now it's like yeah
hustle monday motivation rise and grind
rise and grind baby
i rose and groaned already me too i woke
up so early i'm on my new path
things are going well so far even though
this weekend really tried to derail me
from my path
well we're gonna talk about it this
weekend tried it you guys i'm so happy
to be back i'm feeling
extremely well and recharged renewed
rejuvenated
and happy to be here i miss dude to do
so much
he missed you but honestly i missed you
so [ __ ] much like if i had to do one
more show like
putting you know all the
responsibilities on my back like i would
have had to go to the hospital for
severe back problems well i
appreciate it so much of course wellness
comes first here at the morning toast
we believe in a very um kind of new
progressive philosophy like if you don't
feel like i want to work just don't go
yeah and we also believe that self-care
looks like hard work sometimes sometimes
not all the time not all the time
sometimes self-care looks like a
wellness retreat
yes and for me it did if you guys are
patreon members then you're pretty much
up to speed abreast on the journey
how it went what i was doing so check
out those episodes if you want the
in-depth details of where i was at
there's a vlog
from the actual premises of the wellness
retreat and there's a youtube q a so
there's
so much content so much content pretty
much all of your questions
will get answered in those episodes but
for everybody who's still wondering i
was at pritikin
and i had just the most amazing time i i
feel so well i
it's funny to think back to the girl who
was sitting here contemplating
a wellness retreat you definitely have
like a renew joadave
um and that's really kind of why you
went because you
were visibly like i was low on the
joadave scale and you had to go recharge
and i had to just like undo so many bad
habits from the last year and i feel
like i really
really did that and i have so many
things that i'm looking forward to so
many new
routines habits that i'm going to be
implementing
though so i came back on friday because
saturday and sunday we were celebrating
birthdays for snitch and my husband's
birthday was yesterday and like
this weekend really tried me like it was
a lot of cake and alcohol just like in
your face
saturday morning i was feeling so well
and by sunday night i was so unwell
not even because of the food and alcohol
which was a test
but the allergies my allergies are so
bad my face like i came back so deep
huffed and now i'm
not no but like the allergies are trying
me they're coming for you
they're coming for me so hard it's not
right it's like it's personal
and it's like every time i i come across
like come over a hurdle cross another
obstacle
something else is waiting for me that's
literally life though that's not just
like a you thing
no i know but it's like okay i i
withstood the cake
allergy attack mm-hmm you know yeah um
well i'm really
like so glad that you're back i can't
stress that enough um i always forget
that the lip gloss you have behind this
table is a lip plumper and my lips are
really hurting me so thanks for that
i feel like i have allergies now like my
lips are self-care
looks like stinging lips it really hurts
beauty is pain
it truly is you're gonna look amazing um
and when you're this beautiful like it's
just constantly
pain you're constantly in pain maybe
that's why i'm always in pain
maybe so stunning sickening
um i really i did enjoy friends and
family weeks
but i'm so thrilled that you're back
like there's nothing like sister sister
energy like you are the tia to my tamara
no it's so true and i feel like i have
so much more to give you now yeah i was
running on fumes that's okay that
happens like when you literally like
we work this past year has had highs and
lows and a lot of toxicity and you just
had to go
detoxify i had to expunge the toxicity
and i feel as though i did and i also
feel as though i'm i went because you
know i was like not feeling myself i was
just like
felt like i didn't i didn't feel like i
gained weight this year like the scale
doesn't lie
you know you didn't feel like it like
it's scientifically proven on the scale
i gained weight this year and i was
having a hard time taking it off and i
was just like i want to
reset go somewhere where i can get some
new
tips tricks you know and start a new
lifestyle
and i feel as though i really did that
with where i went
so i just i have not no regrets
no not one single regret that is so
great like making a tough decision and
then like sticking with it and
being glad that you did and it exceeded
my expectations so if
i'm inspiring you to do what i did which
like
everyone's different self-care looks
different for everyone but i just want
to let you know like if you do call and
make a reservation um
use my name like say that i referred you
one cause then i get like bonus points
and two i got ten percent discount for
posters
so let them know i sent you at pritikin
if you feel like if you're feeling
inspired to go do your own research
everyone is different but it was great
for me just use my name 10 discount if
you booked by the end of the month and
go before the end of october yes and if
you go to my wellness retreat on 42nd
street called krispy kreme and you say
my name um they'll tell you to [ __ ] off
and get out yeah they'll say
okay cool that'll be 76.95 she sounds
like like a nice lady
um speaking of that nice ladies
speaking of nice ladies i was able to
bear witness this morning
to your new oh my god you haven't even
been here experiment
research r d i don't know if i would say
that i would call it like you know
a sickening viral content series if i
had to put a name on it okay so it was a
sickening viral context series for me
i thought it was like a science fair
project but um
wow no matter so much respect to the
science fair by the way just
so much respect to the signs there a
quick tangent
you know those videos on facebook that
like no one subscribes to but they just
come up where it's like
does your heat protect and spray really
protect heat and then they spray a piece
of toast and put it in the toaster
that's like
those are science fair experiments by
the way kids these days have it's so
[ __ ] easy head over to facebook watch
and you have literally like a winning
science fair project yeah whereas like
back in the day i literally had to like
scrunch the bottom of the art to be like
just coca-cola or
water bubble faster like dumb [ __ ] oh
that's so funny i remember and i feel
like i'm really scared by this but one
of my science fair projects is like what
does
like what does soda do to your insides
so i like took a
penny and i dropped it in a cup of soda
and a cup of water i left it for like
seven days
and i remember i got like a bad mark
because they were like why does the
penny resemble your
yeah that's a very fair point okay but
then i watch these things on facebook
watch and it's like
why does a piece of toast resemble my
hair
why does it so they use like a thermal
piece of paper and a flat and a
straightening iron why does that
resemble my hair
that is so true no but i do feel moved
by those videos so i just feel like the
injustice was me receiving that bad mark
do you ever have like moments in like
your childhood
that um like accomplishments that really
stick with you
yeah so when i was in the eighth grade
um
there was a science fair and there was
like over 100 entries and there was
three winners and i got an honorable
mention for fourth place which
i didn't get a trophy but like i was
still really proud of like not everyone
got an honorable mention
no that's pretty good for me six people
didn't for a [ __ ] you know
what was your experiment it was all
about fireworks and i actually like
happened
because of the science fair i know that
like a lot of most fireworks are
magnesium based so it was like a
magnesium like it was really creative
that's very partnered with alex brazile
who is a toaster
wow we love to see it we do so we were
talking about
your science fair experiment oh yes my
new tic toc series and reels even though
you know they perform so well on wheels
two of them
one of them hit a million and the other
two are like about to hit a million
views so like
literally i'm so influential on reels
that's like being you know rich in
monopoly money
yeah um but the tick tock series is
going very well um
it's a personal journey but also it's a
good content series always looking for
new content ideas especially on tick
tock so make sure to follow me on tick
tock
girl with no job and it's going well i
mean today was very successful i got a
very good con
uh order recommendation from someone on
tick tock
but it would taste too good but it only
got a six i don't want to spoil it i
want to spoil it okay
it only got the grade that it did
because as much as it was delicious
tasting it's not a realistic order for
every day like that whole thing it was
literally like milk
with a dash of coffee and like 10 sugars
you know i was like
that's not really what i'm looking for
i'm looking for like a something i can
realistically eat every day and not end
up on my 600 pound life
yeah i agree with that but you could
always sub the sugars for splenda
no but it wasn't even the sugar it was
like the syrup like it was just like all
these things
there wasn't even actual splenda in it
like there was no actual sugar it was
just like
literally she gave it to me and i swear
i was like this is a cup of milk like it
was white
yeah so is there anything that's leading
the pack like any
drink but you had to end the series now
by far the best drink i've had is iced
caramel macchiato
but that too i can imagine is like
literally 400 calories and like that's
just not what coffee's supposed to do
like coffee's supposed to be like
good but like you know 100 calories and
then like you [ __ ] it out like
so me just take that that's not what i
need another 800 calorie beverage like i
have enough of those at the bar you know
yeah no i feel you also coffee's like
not supposed to
taste so amazing i refuse to believe
that no i like i barely like the coffee
that i drink but it's
it's a necessity like it's just not
about the frills well now i'm at the
point like in the series where it's not
even really about finding the right
drink it's about like making the best
content because like
a lot of people are on this journey with
me and i'm just i've been really
overwhelmed
with this getting choked up like gwyneth
paltrow commented on it
what did she say did she have a sister i
responded to her like you give me the gp
order she didn't respond i might slide
into the dms no like
you should follow up on that because i
think we could all use
the gp order i think we all really need
one of the pal no and now it's turning
into a thing where like my reels is like
blowing up all these celebs are like
commenting their orders like i think i
should just start like this is
you know stephanie holman's order yeah
this is what stephanie holman drinks
at starbucks at starbucks also uh dunkin
donuts did comment on my tick tock that
they want me to try the charlie
and the thing is is that everyone's
telling me like i don't really even like
coffee so i should go to dunkin donuts
but like
where the [ __ ] is the dunkin donuts like
i live there's there's literally a
starbucks
in between here in my house so it's like
perfect to get to yeah it's all about
convenience but i
i do think you know i don't drink the
devil's brew at starbucks
but i do associate duncan with having
better coffee because i do feel like it
gets rubbed off from the donuts
100 and it has like doughnutty vibes it
has a glazed aroma
yeah like because it's sitting there
with like delicious smelling donuts
you don't get the calories but you get a
donutty vibe no and everyone pretty much
told me like junkin
coffee is better and lighter it's like
not as like burnt
yeah i mean yeah once you're going to
the devil's workshop i don't know why
you think you're going to get something
good
no it's so true but like it's it's
merely convenience
there's so many different what about
like a little boot i know
for your outside of the series so like
obviously you're committed to your craft
you're going to keep going to starbucks
drinking devils so committed but for
your personal
self what about like a little boutique
yeah i need to think like i need to
really explore but you know i don't
leave my house so like that's hard for
me
yeah but you don't think there's a
coffee place on your route between here
and your house there's literally not
just starbucks
just starbucks there's actually is two
starbucks okay
damn we need to see it it's tough but
i'm gonna get to a dunkin donuts
eventually
this is just like a series i really like
would have loved to do if i lived in the
suburbs like because i would make them
in my car i would like look so cute in
my car and like the drive car lighting
car lighting like it would just be
iconic but i literally live in the
greatest city on earth
so yeah but at least you have a cute
studio it's true
so we'll continue to follow you on your
journey um to wellness
yeah wellness looks different for
everyone it looks different for everyone
and as
someone who just believes in wellness
you really deeply
i couldn't ask for anything more for you
well i couldn't ask for anything more
from you than to be sitting right here
and i'm so glad you are here
so glad to dive into all the happening
happening ons
said happenings happening ons happen ons
in the world because you know they tried
but no one could feel that seat you know
as much as i'm sorry that
they tried you i'm glad that my absence
was felt
that's always what you want to hear so
felt but it was great to you know get
new perspectives taylor schrecker and i
like
are the same person but we don't agree
on anything like she was coming off with
like some of the worst takes on summer
house like it was
shocking oh um but brian was great you
know
loved getting traveled like little tips
from him and then there was ben which i
honestly don't want to talk about i'm
still traumatized
okay well i guess without further ado
though it feels like we have
so much to catch up on like i didn't
even scratch the surface
well margo had a little get-together for
her birthday on her roof it was so
delightful to just like
be outside and it was sunny but like it
was also cold so like we were all
dressed like we were
going to different planets but it was
fun and it was fabulous and i got drunk
and i actually like
i mean i see this every monday like i
literally was drinking for 36 hours
and no regrets no regrets no you have so
much making up to do
so much making up to do this is what i
keep saying people are like claudia i
haven't seen you you don't answer the
phone
we're living in a post-pandemic world
like do not look for me like i'm in
mykonos like i'm going places do not
look for me
unless i come for you i think that's
completely fair i think it is too
yeah saturday was really fun like a
great day to be back like from wellness
and then sunday yesterday was zack's
birthday and we just i went to like
every delicious restaurant in manhattan
this weekend and it was it was hard
i did my best to stay pritikin friendly
i think i did an okay job but this week
i'm back on the grind back on the ground
that's what mondays are for rise grind
hustle schmussel rise grind and get back
on the grind
yeah and clean your apartment yeah oh
and do your returns i have a boxes of
things i need to return
same and i just i can't get myself to do
it like
also my closet organizers are coming
back on wednesday they come like now
like once every
six or eight months it's been a while
because of coved but i'm gonna vlog it
for patreon because like my closet is a
mess like it's actually embarrassing
not only it's like my all my color
coordination out of whack like i've got
you know undies in the long sleeve shirt
drawer like i'm all over the place yeah
once you post that video you're gonna
inspire me yeah no it's the best feeling
like now my apartment's getting like
messier and messier because i've
it's kind of like how we used to go to
fat camp and like the weeks leading up
like you would just eat whatever you
want because it's like whatever i'm
going to fat camp next week so now i'm
just like
living in a pig's decks i'm like
whatever i'm organizing my closet next
week
yeah so can't wait for that you also
inspired me to go to zara cause claudia
posted her
czar spring haul and i must go i was so
influenced by you and if you don't keep
that like retro dress
i want it the green and yellow it's all
yours wow can't wait
can't return it because zara they just
have like annoying [ __ ] policies like
i hate stories that just like make [ __ ]
up like we want to have this fake ass
role so like we're gonna
yeah but they do but they do and they
can they can and they will and they
did and they did so now i guess without
further ado
it is time for the past five stories
that you yes you yep yep yep don't be
confused it's
i'm talking to you you're looking behind
you like me yeah you are you
you are in the backseat of the taxi are
you talking to me
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and i am just honored and humbled to let
you guys know that today's episode is
brought to you by pandora jewelry
it's not easy to express such a profound
relationship when your connection with
mom is stronger than words
tell her you love her with the love
captured in pandora jewelry
love pandora jewelry are you okay
this is so exciting about pandora this
season pandora has gifts for every mom
with new
designs in their collection of
contemporary classics um
pandora offers more than just charms
with a wide variety of rings necklaces
earrings and bracelets
all of their jewelry can be customized
to fit all styles and personalities
it's a great way to express a connection
that's stronger than words with symbols
of love and gratitude like hearts
infinity symbols angel wings and family
trees they remind us
of remind us how special mother's day
mothers are this is your reminder you
guys mother's day is this sunday
head over to pandora julie to not only
get a great gift but also be the
favorite child
you can shop safely in store with
pandora styling experts to find the
perfect gift for any mom on your list
but you can also buy online with
in-store pickup and curbside pickup
at select locations where you can
contact your local store to learn more
thank the mom and your life for always
be being there with a sparkling gift
from pandora jewelry
you really can't go wrong with jewelry
for mother's day and pandora julie just
has you covered
in every department for every mom in
your life this is olivia's
first mother's day like it's a big day
you guys i heard
i heard there was kayla was spotted
shopping at pandora jewelry
i can either confirm nor deny those
rumors but you're not wrong
i saw it on dumas go to us.pandora.net
toast to start shopping or find a store
near you that's us.pandora.net
toast okay let's get into the stories
first
up what everybody is talking about jlo
and ben
affleck are hanging out apparently
allegedly there is photos though that
would say
that they're hanging out after the split
from a-rod that is so crazy the oscar
winner has been spotted multiple times
going to jlo's california home during
the day
page six years after having been picked
up in a white escalade suv
that allegedly belongs to j-lo and then
taken to her near my mansion
jayla what sends her chauffeur to pick
up at ben affleck
yeah i'm curious on the logistics was
jayla driving the car
or no no no i think like jlo has been
spotted in the back seat of this car so
the pair has not been spotted together a
source till page six security picks him
up at a nearby location and drops him
off after spending a few hours at her
house oh so they're being secretive
they're being secretive but still
getting caught interesting you know this
is like so traumatizing like
when you break up with someone and they
get back together with like someone they
used to date
because then it's like what was the
point of all this you know
yeah it's literally the jordan mcgraw oh
for me
no that's not how i see it i see this as
like
brad pitt and jennifer aniston where
it's like everybody's like shipping them
back together but like he disrespected
her in such a profound way that like
i don't know how she could ever accept
him so like to me this would never
happen because like
what we were so young at the time but
the way that i remember it going down
was like jlo and ben affleck were like
the talk of the town everything
everywhere getting married and like
he called it off can i say like some
kind of runaway bride
controversial sure i don't really feel
like what brad pitt did to jennifer
aniston was disrespect her like i think
the way the media covered it was like
making jennifer out to be like the sad
sack but like okay he fell in love with
someone else and he like
broke up with jennifer and went to the
other person like that's people
fall in and out of love like what are we
supposed to do we hate them they do but
like when you're
cheating and when you're following
cheating when you're falling in love
with someone when you're married to
someone else like
that's not respectable no but i agree it
happens
like [ __ ] happens but then that person
probably swears to herself every single
night i will never
take this person and imagine if that
person was the sexiest man alive like
how do you
with the sexiest woman alive like you
just how do you cope with that
you don't you don't no honestly like
before i go to bed i pray for jennifer
anderson like that must be
that must have been hard yeah so i just
associate
this with that era no and it's just like
that same disrespect like
you can't help how you feel of course
but like you can help how you react to
something so they were engaged this was
like a little bit before my time but i
obviously knew they were an iconic man
and then and then like i don't know the
timeline exactly but swiftly he was with
jennifer garner
um he swapped out his jennifers
literally
and they're both equally as stunning but
you know what i bet jayla looks
at ben and jen and was like so glad
that's not me but now she's sending her
escalade no but now it's like when you
date after you have kids this is like
how i feel about dolores from real
housewives of new jersey like
after your initial big marriage for your
marc anthony and you have your kids and
you're just like dating like for fun
like
it doesn't have to be so serious yeah
yeah that's why dolores everyone's
getting on her ass about like marrying
david like who cares like if you're with
someone who like
you know makes you happy and like you
have your own money you don't need a man
and like he's good for sex like
what's the problem like it's all good
yeah i totally agree
people are like blowing up my phone i
have to turn on do not disturb that's my
new favorite thing do not disturb
welcome to 2021 i'm happy to be here
because do not do serve is so amazing
don't disturb me it goes from 11 25 at
night
to when i wake up in the morning it's on
and then when i do the show it's always
on
i'm just learning these things but the
worst thing is forgetting to take it off
and like
literally like you're like somebody died
like you know like
so many no i was in a massage and my
phone was going crazy and i literally
had to get up in the middle
do not disturb and i was not disturbed
oh it's so important to not be disturbed
especially in a massage yeah so back to
the subject at hand
crazy crazy crazy i personally like i'm
not
if if they want to be together and
that's what jayla wants of course my
ship it's ready
we'll set sail whenever she says
immediately but like i just
i'm kind of feeling better for her i
mean ben affleck has
such chaotic energy like he's just like
kind of messy as [ __ ]
and jayla's just like it's actually hard
we were talking about this last night at
dinner just like
jlo is so together like
in every way and i just can't even like
come up with someone who's good enough
for her and honestly if i did it would
have been a-rod and he just disappointed
me so wholeheartedly
so she's just having fun probably and
you know what dip back into the ben
affleck pond do we do whatever you want
okay yeah i agree do whatever you want
but that's just like where my head went
no i feel that as well like but at some
point like so much time has passed like
does it even matter
i don't know some wounds like i never
forgive
but i can't forget i want to forgive you
and i want to forget you yeah from
lagoon hills the hills yeah yeah okay
are you ready for our next story
i'm honestly not theo's looking like so
sexy i don't know how i'm just supposed
to like
go about my day acting like all is
normal when there's like literally like
a sex
marilyn monroe is on my lap you know i
know like what would you do if marilyn
monroe just sat on your lap
i don't know did you go about your
business no no so how can i be expected
to
look he's like arching his back he's
literally like so hot and he's like so
comfortable and he's like warm asleep
so beautiful i miss him so much i missed
him so much too but
he needs to know that billy eilish has
debuted a new look for british vogue
she says it's all about what makes you
feel good billy eilish is ushering in a
new era in the june issue of british
vogue
which was unveiled on sunday the 19 year
old singer ditched her trademark baggy
clothes
for a classic old-timey pinup look an
idea which she came up with herself
apparently
i mean it's not like the most creative
idea well it's like i mean
this seems to be you know a trend
amongst major pop stars with every era
comes a new look
it's very taylor swift um and so this
is her new look we had seen the blonde
and we
talked about it a few weeks ago and so
now we have
the aesthetic that will be accompanying
it i'm completely and totally here for
it
i mean it's such a diversion a departure
excuse me
from what we've known green hair baggy
clothes big shorts
big shirts big sneakers um i love get
you a girl who can do both
yeah but i think like what's so crazy
about this is like i
i just imagined that i would never see
like
billy eyelashes like shoulders like i
just never i just like
i'm just now adjusting to life like
knowing what billy eilish's body looks
like you know
not to be a freak but like it's just she
like made such a statement and i thought
it was so cool that like
she really got so successful like just
for the music like there was no
hoopla yeah but i and i also thought at
the time in
when she was in her first era of like
the of the bagginess that that was going
to be like a permanent
me for her so now she's done a total 180
normalized normalize changing your mind
or just like doing whatever the [ __ ] you
want
normalize doing whatever the [ __ ] you
want i just didn't see this one coming
and that's literally what she says in
the interview she's like
yeah i wanted to wear baggy clothes and
now i don't like great you literally
don't need to say anything else
yeah say less period period yeah well
she looks amazing
she does pictures are sickening the
styling is everything of the sort
styling but also i do not know because
she's always wearing baggy clothes she's
an enormous tattoo
yes it's like the biggest thing i've
ever seen yes it's like a snake right
yeah little slithering down like her
belly button to her
right thigh yeah i don't know if it's a
snake but it does have snakey vibes it
has slithery like tendencies
yeah but also looks like mermaid to me
that was the most interesting part of
the whole thing a big
big old tattoo who knew who knew nobody
but now we do
maybe we'll uncover more tattoos in this
new era yes i wonder if the music will
be changing
with the aesthetic because this is like
very like
scooter
like her her music and the energy of the
music really matched that green hair
like it was literally
like yeah symbiote this is very like
katy perry i kissed a girl you know it's
very like
jazz club 1950 it's like scuba dive
screw up screw up screw up scoot up dude
oh you guys that's a sneak peek of new
billy island you don't
you can't get it anywhere else like
share it don't pirate it
but that is the second time a major
artist has reached out to us to debut
their new music first it was kanye west
that one was real second time it was the
skeet you do
justice israel billy just israel we
become like a really
like a cornerstone of the music industry
over here i completely agree
it's it's hard actually like putting the
whole music industry on your back
it is but you do it with such great we
do it to get that
are you ready for our next story not
unless it involves a little scooter
scooter
daddy is it the next story brought to
you by coors pure it is
it really really is what if it wasn't it
would be awkward
things are hard right now but to be
honest living a healthy life has always
been hard
motivation in the health space is strong
is in
sorry i'm literally having a stroke
today motivation in the house so excited
about these sponsors literally like
actually coors pure is
everything of the sort and the toasters
especially the tipsy toasters are gonna
lose their mind
so when life gets when life gets to be
too much
overwhelming grab a coarse pure an
organic beer that is aggressive about
balance and meets people where they are
the with enthusiastic
enthusiastic positivity it's organic but
chill about it
because having a lifestyle can be really
hard you push yourself every day getting
better and better but it can be
overwhelming
living a healthy lifestyle is important
but it shouldn't stop you from enjoying
your life and i feel like that's what
you learned over these last two weeks
that is when you reach for quartz pure
it's all about org it's all organic and
has zero sugar so you can enjoy it
without feeling guilty
um new course pure is refreshingly
simple beer with organic barley organic
hops
and water at 92 calories and zero
sugar it is the perfect beer to
celebrate the winds of everyday life
whether you got that run in or just got
as far as putting on your running
clothes course pure
celebrates you jackie goes for the runs
i just put my sneakers on
course pure is the perfect beer to
celebrate the winds of everyday life so
when you want to enjoy a beer without
the guilt
reach for coors pure it's organic but
chill about it
go to coorspure.com c-o-o-r-s-p-u-r-e
to see where you can find course pure
celebrate responsibly coors
brewing company albany georgia love it
i just learned that it's albany not
albany in georgia
not in new york of course so our next
story jessica simpson claims publicists
told celebs not to date her jessica
simpson went on the drew barrymore show
and in an interview she said i was the
person to run from because every guy
would be listening to their publicist
stay away stay away you'll never be a
respected actor you'll never be a
respected musician if you're dating her
simpson who is now john mayer begs to
differ well
that was sim she's now married mother of
three but she was referring to
her experience dating post-divorce from
her first husband nick lachey
quote well i have dated some a couple
musicians so
some under the radar that people don't
know about oh i would
love to know who well this article says
that she was dating adam levine
for um a little bit and i don't recall
that me neither but maybe that was one
of the under the radar ones
yeah hmm very interesting very
interesting i love a jessica simpson
factoid it's been about a year and a
half
since the month of jessica simpson and
the book and
everything and i i think soon we'll have
more jessica simmons in moments because
she has those amazon projects coming out
yes and ashley's writing a book too
right
i think she might have already written
one oh i guess it wasn't that popular
um no you're right like every time we
like it hasn't yet
talk about jessica simpson it's like a
nugget of perfection like she's just at
a place in her life where she gives
no [ __ ] like about anyone or anything
and she'll just say whatever she wants
she doesn't have to protect anyone
she doesn't work in the music industry
anymore she's like a self-made woman
so she could literally say whatever the
[ __ ] she wants and that's why her book
was so good like she literally didn't
give a [ __ ]
yeah the book was so good you guys if
you haven't read it yet treat yourself
one of the best books i read in 2020 and
they're turning it into like an amazon
series right amazon series
like a scripted also she's doing like a
docu sort of series with amazon
so it's very like what wendy williams
did with lifetime like a documentary and
a duck you series like
yes exactly i love her we reported last
week
with taylor strecker that she uh
throughout the ski all the scales in her
home a few years ago and it's like
changed her life
and she's like yeah so i just like fit
him into my clothes and then when i
don't i just
get new ones like it was so brilliantly
simplistic
truckers for jessica simpson throwing
out her scales yes and i'm with them 100
100 wellness goals for sure for sure
okay our next story we have some
kentucky derby news
two big pieces of news the first being
that medina spirit won the 2021 kentucky
derby
because i don't know her congratulations
okay all the equines involved
um but also the trainer of medina
sparrow this is like his
that he just set the record for how many
horses
have one so like that's exciting and
then i would say the bigger news is that
shailene woodley and aaron rodgers
enjoyed the kentucky derby
with miles teller and kelly sperry yes i
did see that and i too
was shook to my core because they all
looked so fabulous and that little prom
picture they had with like
all the couples was so [ __ ] cute no
literally me
looking at that picture was just zooming
zoom
zoom they looked so cute i just feel
like miles teller and kelly sperry have
really excellent taste in like hollywood
friends like they're always hanging out
with like the best people
the best of the best the creme de la
creme the creme de la creme that means
cream by the way
i know some of you are from new jersey
and i just like if i lived in hollywood
or like was like
traditionally famous i would be friends
with the sperry teller clan just because
like i like who they hang out with 100
and i do think that that is a good
reflection on shailene and aaron
yes you know i'm becoming like a big fan
of that i know
i know if you can believe it i know
people can change
people can change also rogers has been
in the news like all week
yeah he's like not going back to
wisconsin do you see the drama
i've been so you guys last week how's
everyone feeling anything could happen
and anything did i heard
that like the cowboys came as close as
as one could really come to like pulling
a kevin costner and like really
yeah they like traded picks and they got
some for next year and they wound up
also getting the player that they wanted
that's so interesting because nobody
does it like kevin costner
and always always always remember
anything can happen on draft day
that i have two things to say one i've
been like so invested in the nfl draft
like
one because that guy you know the one
the one trevor lawrence yes
obsessed with his wife like they're
married like straight out of college
they're so [ __ ] cute like
and he's just like so interesting to me
like he's got such a long neck like i'm
i feel like that makes him a really good
quarterback
and two like the the videos watching
like
when people get the call and then like
their whole family screams like i cannot
those are like i'm addicted to watching
like military homecoming videos
and i'm also addicted to watching people
like get the phone call from the gm
because like
it's literally like these people like in
30 seconds like their life
changes like life changes like watching
someone's dreams come true there's
really nothing like it no it's and they
all get emotional it's like so stunning
they're always there with their moms
always like everyone just like respects
their moms and
the first thing they say is that they're
gonna buy their mama house and i
literally saw a video
of a player and i'm sorry i don't know
what team it was or
he um most of most of them especially in
covet they take the phone calls
from their house or um
whatever they take it from their house
but he took it at um like a local
shelter that like really helped him when
he was a kid and like all the kids were
there like freaking out like
it was so cute they were just there are
so many great draft day
stories yeah that are worth telling that
are worth telling and there's so many
like fictional ones like in the movie
that are also worth telling and i think
they should make a draft day sequel
because there's still so much more out
there yeah i mean i did see draft day
recently and like you had hyped it up a
lot like it was definitely a fine movie
but
now that i'm like really invested in
drafting i really feel like it could
have been more powerful
no i i completely disagree and you know
what trevor lawrence's
pick tells me about trevor lawrence that
his teammates went to his birthday party
100 that was a great part of the movie
yeah
that the teammates didn't go to the
birthday party no i'm not a team player
trevor definitely seems like a team
player
yeah and like his wife is stunning and
they literally just got married and like
the pictures like cool plots it's like
just like
sickening the ride down so cute i'm so
happy for everyone who's drafted
i was really hoping she was a toaster
she gave me such toaster energy but
after a small bit of research
she's not a toaster yet but it's never
too late to become a toaster it's never
too late to become a redhead but
speaking of being late actually this
month's episode
is going to be it's going to be late
bye a week we can't get all the girls
together to record it and it's so
important that we're all together so
it's being postponed one week will be
the second thursday in may
doing it it's just not the same and i
would rather
wait and get it right than have to do it
remotely
i'm done with zoom i completely agree
but back to dr uh the derby derby
shaylee aaron miles kelly oh yeah he's
been in the news a lot sorry i'm just
like retracting
yeah i don't really know like the d
because they attracted a quarterback
because it was draft day and anything
could happen you know what i love
watching those videos on tic-tac-toe
people's lives getting changed when they
get the call from the draft day
um happy for shayleen like they look
like they're the best time
and i just really feel like this i just
feel like sometimes you don't really
like someone
and then like it takes them being like
she's obviously like really happy like
in this relationship and i'm like
feeling her happiness for her
but i just i feel like it's never too
late to change your mind and i just want
to stress that
like because if if it was too late to
change your mind
i wouldn't be experiencing like the love
that i have for this song right now by
miranda lambert and l king
and i'm literally the biggest miranda
lambert
[Music]
it's so [ __ ] good for me baby drunk
and i don't wanna
come home so good it's so good and like
if i had written miranda lambert off
like i had years ago just because i was
so
like ignorant i would never be like
living my life this morning dancing to
that song giving me a schwa dave to
start my monday yeah some serotonin for
that monday morning so that's just your
reminder it's never too late to change
your mind right and also another great
example
courtney kardashian and travis sparker
like a relationship where you can see
someone being so happy
which is how you feel about that person
exactly like to me courtney was always
giving
off like miserable vibes for someone who
like literally has so much money and is
so stunning and like has the best life
i mean of course you never know what
goes on behind closed doors but now it's
like
she has this excuse me je ne sais quoi
de vivre and it's rubbing off and it's
like making me like her and i said like
she's literally in the running to being
like one of my favorite kardashians
yeah yeah craziness they're going so hot
and
so heavy it's scary i know like the ship
it's like we have this huge
massive vessel and it's just it's
careening
you know it's going 100 miles an hour
it's about to get stuck in the suez like
that's how fast it's going
we're not or maybe it's just like we'll
continue around the world in 180 days
like who knows
i think the most interesting thing about
this whole relationship is what i've
learned about travis barker that he
um doesn't fly he doesn't no he was in
that plane crash with
with when when most people died except
for him and someone else
so literally they're in on jerry they
take this enormous [ __ ] tour bus he
tours all around the country
and when he goes to london he takes the
qe2 he takes two weeks to get to london
that's how he tours fabulous yeah wow
that's why they're in that bus
got it i thought maybe he was just on
tour i didn't think too hard about it
no he was in that like famous plane
crash a private plane that went down
and him and dj am were the only ones who
survived and then dj am years later
ended up passing away like it's a cra
he's had lived like a crazy life wow wow
i didn't know that so courtney's like
into the bus life now i like kind of
love that for her
love it i mean we're we've always been
about the bus life we've been taking the
bus since we were little
and best memories are made on the bus
and i think that's why courtney and
travis are having so much fun yes
they're on the bus and when you're on
the bus the wheels on the bus they go
round and round
you know what they say like you have
beer goggles you also get bus goggles
like your life is just different on the
road right it's like that episode of
real housewives of dallas when they're
in the
rv rv and all and it was just like wild
and joao de vivre
the bus life you guys what episode did
we do i think it was a patreon episode
of good news
where we did the story about like buses
and jackie and i like
lost our [ __ ] mind it was literally a
45 minute episode we were just cackling
the whole time yeah no the story about
the buses they like arranged the buses
to say like 20 20. to celebrate the kids
the graduating class
yeah and it was like
it's still funny okay ready for our
fifth and final story
no not if it's the fifth avenue story
that is not brought to you by zip
recruiter oh my god it is the fifth and
final story brought to you by
ziprecruiter
and you'll find out why soon if you're a
business owner who's hiring you probably
face a lot of challenges when it comes
to finding the right person for your
role
that's why hiring can feel like trying
to find a needle in a haystack sure you
can post your job to some job boards but
then all you can do is hope that the
right person comes along
which is why you should try ziprecruiter
for free at ziprecruiter.com
toast when you post a job on
ziprecruiter it gets sent out to over
100 top job sites with one click
then zip matching technology finds
people with the right skills and
experience
for your job and actively invites them
to apply in fact zip recruiter is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day it's no wonder over 2.3 million
businesses have come to zip recruiter
for their hiring needs
including the morning toast a few years
ago we've actually used zip recruiters
starting a few years ago and it is very
efficient and you get a lot of
candidates
really fast while other companies
overwhelm me with way too many options
zip recruiter finds you what you're
looking for the needle in the haystack
and right now you can try zip recruiter
for free at this
address ziprecruiter.com toast once
again make sure to go to
ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
love it okay fifth and final story a
little business that's very pertinent to
our situation
it's very personal it's business
it's a little biz news that's personal
yes verizon is selling yahoo and aol
businesses
to apollo global management for 5
billion
verizon will sell its media group to
private equity firm apollo global
management for 5 billion
the companies announced on monday the
sale allows verizon to offload
properties from the former internet
empires of aol and yahoo
verizon will keep a 10 stake in the
company and it will be
rebranded to just yahoo so now people
like why this is pertinent is like
nobody cares yahoo and aol like talk
about two dead brands like
literally they're brandy glanville no
matter how many people buy you like you
will never be relevant
but this is especially personal for us
because if you've been here from the
beginning you know that we used to be
owned
by verizon aol yahoo and co and co
and then they canceled our show for
reasons i really don't feel like going
into but you can read it in my book
available on amazon
100 so then the second our show got
cancelled
stocks declined plummeted business
in the tank verizon bought aol and yahoo
not at the same time but together for
about nine billion dollars and now
they're selling for five billion and
experts are saying that the four billion
dollar discrepancy
is because of the cancellation of the
morning breath but that's what
no honestly the fact that those two
losery ass companies are worth
five billion dollars and like i'm not is
shocking to me like talk about two
companies
with less going on explain this is where
i don't understand business and i'd like
to think of myself as a savvy business
woman like we've built this brand like
we are not dumb
explain to me how two luxury ass
companies with nothing to offer
are worth five billion dollars like
that's where i just don't understand the
tech space because i think most people
would regard aol and yahoo as like
dated 90s brands with literally nothing
going on and that's just not
that's not even me being bitter that's
just facts yeah
straight facts explain it to me um i
personally can't but it reminds me
because i just watched the
wework documentary have you watched it
no but i've heard it i've heard a lot
about it
okay i felt like so many different ways
about it i thought the documentary was
really good i remember when wework was
like always in the news and i was just
like scrolling past i think we might
have reported it but
because they like went so hot and then
they were broke like watch the
documentary whatever we might have
reported on it like i clearly didn't
understand it because that's not what i
saw from the documentary what happened
that they went public and then they went
bankrupt no they never
went fully public because the documents
that they had to like put forth before
the ipo like showed that it was just
like fraudulent so
no not fraudulent and that's what's
confusing to me because they had the
customers like they had people who
wanted to be in the spaces like those
were
premium spaces like they were putting on
these events and
these spaces and people were showing up
like it was all happening but i guess
they tried to just expand too quickly
they started to spend money that they
didn't have yet because they thought a
20 billion
investment was coming in and then the
investment did not come in from softbank
and then they were in yeah and then they
were in the trouble
even more in the red and so then they
tried to push forward with this ipo
but the documents like the way that the
founder and his wife like talked it was
just like you know like
shady mcshade or scene buzzword central
buzzword
central like the collective we there is
no i
and we like just nonsense and like the
people there is no i and we but there is
an ew
but there is if you flip it me
that's good um the people at wall street
were like oh no they saw right through
they saw right there so they wound up
not going public
and then the founders stepped down but
they still had to lay off a bunch of
employees and now they're trying to come
back
and you know if only they had hung on
for a little bit longer then they could
have said that the like dissolution of
wework
was because of covid because like it's
literally the anti-covet
so is we work not around anymore so it
is now it's under new management they're
they're trying to come back and stuff i
think like it is still around i just
like feel so proud not to make it about
us but a few years ago but let's make it
about us
because we we know a few years ago we
were looking for office space and so of
course we were like we work that's where
you know young people work young people
with like entrepreneurial
spirit go to work and so we looked at
like a sickening building the lipstick
jungle building yes
do you guys remember that tv show
lipstick jungle they all worked in this
bag because it was like four episodes
it was so good the fact that it got
cancelled means this generation has no
taste
100 they were like these fabulous
working women and they worked in this
like sickening iconic building
and it's i don't know what the
building's called but it was the
lipstick jungle building it's the
lipstick jungle building to us wework
has
some floors there so we took a tour and
we were only three people at the time me
you and snitch
and so we just needed like three desks
and like just everything about it was
all wrong for us it was literal prison
cell for like
ten thousand dollars a month the prices
the vibes were just like we were not
about it and so like
we saw through we work but like also we
also just like couldn't afford it but we
couldn't afford it but according to the
documentary
they were like slinging deals like
giving people like eight months free
like they never offered us that [ __ ] no
in fact the girl had an attitude because
we came in and like we just hated it but
we were lovely of course then we came on
the podcast and we were like we went to
a wework and it stunk
and it was literally a prison cell and
she wrote us an email like following up
here on the prison cell like she
obviously heard it
like don't take it so personally it was
a prison cell there was like one window
seriously don't take it personally no
it's not like you built the building
like you're not adam
yeah but also but they did do a really
good job and in the documentary too like
they had these huge events that was
literally like
fire festival but successful like they
had like camp rework like camp toast but
like for customers
for people who use the space like
for the employees and everything and
like they really did that [ __ ] like they
put on these massive things and they
followed through and like they would
open up new spaces like so
many places so fast and and it was
really nice looking and and things
worked and whatnot so they got off the
ground so that's where i'm confused
where it's like
you had the customers like you had
people in the door
at in the desks and still like it's just
like how i don't understand how uber is
not profitable when i give them all of
my money
i will never understand that like get an
accountant like
fix yourself like you literally like
there's no reason uber should be making
no money no it's so crazy they have all
of mine
that's where i don't understand the tech
space at all and that's what we're
saying like excuse me
that make no money are worth so much
money yet companies who
make who take all your money are not
profitable
yeah so like aol and yahoo like the only
people who
pay money to aol like literally forgot
that they paid for it 10 years ago and
are still paying like for their
dhl roundup they forgot their login and
they can't cancel the subscription 100
that's literally me with barkbox like
every month it comes and i'm like please
cancel it
i can't remember my login and it's a lot
it's 21
a month and theo is not into it anymore
we are overflowing with [ __ ] toys and
treats like
in a lifetime no dog can literally go
through all the dogs and
all the treats and toys that they send
it's so funny
it's so overwhelming and i'm on this the
cheapest plan yeah
and it's h o overwhelming and i just
found out that every
bark box toy like when a dog rips
through it if you actually open it up
there's another toy inside it's like a
special
thing about that it's like matryoshka
dolls it's russian egg dolls yeah
fabric whatever so it's like you get
four [ __ ] toys a month you really get
eight
it's crazy wow theo's living large
living large
couldn't be less interested never even
looks at the toys well now that he's
grown he's like not into toys but maybe
he'll give some to his cousins
i desperately need to cancel my bark box
like if you work at barkbox like please
reach out like i just want to cancel it
like i've had
i love it it's a great service i've had
a great time but i've had enough
same also i'm on a birchbox
um yeah subscription i love it actually
but
who's paying for it i don't know if i am
no i'm on a birchbox like
weekly subscription i get men's and
women me too
who is paying for it i don't know
apparently yes it's not me
it's not me i checked all my credit
cards i literally don't know where it's
coming from it's like manna from heaven
literally
um so those were the festival stories i
feel as though you needed to know them
can't believe aol and yahoo are worth
five billion dollars and we're not like
we
actually have customers yeah shocking
stuff that's disgusting
i'm about to storm the apollo office and
demand an explanation
um happy for them yeah whatever and
happy for apollo like
you literally just flushed five billion
dollars down the toilet when you could
have just given it to me
hundred percent i think um anything else
you want to talk about before we
wrap it up no i'm still behind on tv but
i'm catching up this week i'm in the
middle of
such a good book called an american
heiress by
daisy goodwin who also wrote a book on
queen victoria that's the premise for
the show
victoria so i'm really enjoying it when
you hear the word eris what do you think
of
eris yeah or heiress i said it weird
whatever i don't know
i literally always think of that
commercial from when we were kids serena
williams fragrance
and she called it inerys which is serena
backwards but it's also like an
heiress and i thought it was like the
smartest [ __ ] thing when i was a kid
and i always think of like she's hitting
the tennis jacket and then like the
bottle turns around and it's like
inerras
by serena williams that's so beautiful
yeah that's not what i thought of
okay i didn't have an association but
now i do we usually have like the same
childhood association so i thought you
might maybe it was like on the toilet
um well that sounds like a great book
i'm excited for you yeah no it's nice i
i the past few books that i've read they
i just haven't been enraptured and so
it's nice to be enraptured once again
theo literally just got up and i i've
sweat marks on my thighs because he was
just like
so but he knows when the show is over
and like that's when he gets up it's
crazy
and it's like sometimes it's like
pencils down that's all she wrote but
it's also sometimes like theo jumped off
the couch that's when you know it's over
and sometimes it's like the bell doesn't
excuse you i excuse you and that's theo
but by the way for the record the belt
literally excuses you that's
why i was created um thank you guys so
much so another teacher should have a
bunch of late kids
i get in trouble because you couldn't
like get your curriculum in the 45
minutes that you were supposed to
another teacher is waiting for her
students and she has the exact same
amount of time as the teacher
that came before her yeah and yet
you have no respect for her none or him
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning shows the millennium morning
show where we deliver the fast life
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
where podcasts can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
hear radio catwalks all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning chelsea five star review
about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing day monday don't forget to rise
and grind
and we'll see you tomorrow